more than five months after the first
confirmed coronavirus illness in this
country cases are surging again to
record levels there were more than
38,000 cases reported yesterday that's
according to the Cova tracking project
now that surpasses the previous high of
about 36,000 back in April the three
most populated US states California
Florida and Texas all reported record
daily cases in Texas hospitalizations
have hit record highs for 13 straight
days in that state's biggest city of
Houston 97% of ICU beds are occupied at
Texas Medical Center which is billed as
the largest Medical Complex in the world
officials there say if trends continue
the center could become overwhelmed and
with all that in mind let's get to our
doctor David agus who joins us from Los
Angeles now dr. agus good morning
there's a lot to get to I want to begin
with these dramatic numbers of surge in
cases we knew we would expect little
spikes as states reopened this doesn't
seem little what concerns you most about
it you're right Tony this is you know
inning one we're all stayed at home we
knew what to do we knew we had to stay
at home and we all did what we were
supposed to do in the case rate in the
United States fell pretty dramatically
but aiming to where the rules are
different all over the place we don't
know what to do and I think we're seeing
that and we're seeing particularly young
people go out and go back to the way
they were so they're not going down a
level going out with mass and social
distancing they're going back to the way
they were they said you know it's not
gonna affect me dramatically I can't
handle this I have to go back and then
they come and they could spread to
others so this spread these number
increases are scary and obviously we're
seeing it like the report in Texas where
the hospitals are overwhelmed why is it
that we have this double-digit increase
nationally in cases but the death count
is declining the two-week averages in
the number of fatalities on the way down
why the lag well because we have an age
drift downwards
you know United States is four percent
of the global population yet 25% of the
in cases of Kobe 19 in the world we're
seeing this increase in cases now in the
United States but the younger people
they're hospitalized many of them but
they're not going to an ICU as much and
not obviously dying as much so the death
rate is staying stable but this is still
worrisome because they could spread the
virus and it stays asymptomatic people
that really worried me because they
could spread to others without knowing
it and so when cases are up the numbers
of cases of spreading are growing and
it's scary right now in this country
yeah you mentioned some new rules one
that comes to mind is New York New
Jersey and Connecticut imposing a
two-week quarantine on visitors from
states that are seeing a surge will that
be affective and then bigger picture are
these states with a surge likely to need
a lockdown to get it under control
well we saw it the other way a few
months ago right you couldn't go from
Florida to New York and now you can't go
from New York I mean but you couldn't
you can't go from New York to Florida
I'm saying it backwards we saw it in the
old days is that you couldn't have gone
from New York to Florida now you can't
go from Florida to New York so yeah I
think that they have to do this is that
there are places in the country where
there are very high numbers of cases and
they have to in a sense be on lockdown
and other states are gonna say I don't
want people from that state coming into
my state and we're all gonna start to
protect each other you know states with
different rules makes it very confusing
we don't have national leadership on
what to do it's all at the local level
and that makes it difficult cuz you
don't know exactly what the rules are
yeah
the United part of the United States
seems to be missing from the the public
health response but we have heard from
President Trump who yesterday teased
what he called a beautiful surprise on
the vaccine front do you have any idea
what he's talking about I'm not always
quite sure I understand what he's
talking about but I can say is that the
results on the vaccines look very
promising in that right now thousands of
patients have been vaccinated there have
yet to be significant side effects and
what I think it's encouraging is that
almost everyone is having an immune
response realize that the vaccine is
going to be a little different I think
with men words
we build it maybe two shots so one shot
on day zero another shot three weeks
later and then we'll see how long the
vaccine laughs so my gut is there will
be a vaccine here in the fall and we're
going to start to vaccinate the country
so having light at the end of the tunnel
I think it's very positive and hopefully
that will enable all of us to say just a
couple more months of hunkering down and
doing a change in behavior because in
the end we're gonna get back to a new
normal but we will get back to a way of
life that were more comfortable yeah Wow
the fall sounds like a timetable a lot
of people would be rooting for doctor
David agus thank you very much much
appreciated